[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
padres hosting the cubs today
he went one for three against the uh
cubs last night padres losing
7-1 fernando tatis jr looking good there
how you doing today i'm doing good i'm
doing good papi how are you
i'm doing okay uh what do you do all day
before you get ready to go to the game
anything interesting uh uh
homeboy over here is pretty early so uh
not much to do just eat
some good breakfast i go to the park uh
have you ever been leaked no
if you will what happened
uh i don't even want to know but that
that's been one of my biggest fears
since i started playing baseball i have
a professional career
what was your second best sport growing
up
basketball how good were you
pretty good well wait a minute who plays
in the nba the way you played growing up
uh i was kind of a russell westbrook
oh okay so full effort
you know rebounds points not a good
shooter but you could score
exactly when did you realize though that
baseball's going to be my future
uh that was kind of my dream since since
i was a kid you know see him at that
play
coming to the ballpark and seeing him
just you know doing the his show and
just coming to the park by
itself it was since a kid i was always
dreaming about
it give me the all-star you remember
meeting
and i'll start well i remember jose
reyes
i met maguire when i was a kid
david wright um
that's a pretty big list but did you
talk
how old were you at the time uh
at that time i was like 10. okay
but do you ask them questions you get to
work out do you want to you know play
catch with them
no to work out it was more like robinson
canal
that he was uh he helped me a lot
through my mind
career what do you mean oh he helped you
or held you
yeah help help help me how did he help
you
uh he was like one of my he's still one
of my mentors
like we're from the same hometown so i
always ask them a lot
questions experience and you know just
just the process
how many times have you gone to the
plate in your career
wanting to hit a home run
very few and it almost doesn't it
doesn't work
[Laughter]
dude okay you go up there and you go i'm
going to take this guy deep
why does that why doesn't it work out
and then it works out when you're not
thinking about that um
i feel like you just become a better
hitter when you're not trying to hit a
home run
you know and uh uh i feel like that's
like pew hitter
does like um he's trying to put
put a good swing on a good pitch and the
ball is going to take care of itself
and then after that uh you said i don't
run but when you're trying to hit a home
run boy that doesn't work i only done it
like once
in my big league career uh what do you
make of all of this
uh the pictures with putting tacky stuff
on the ball
uh like have you noticed anything with
pitchers could you tell
if they put something sticky on the
baseball when they throw it
it's different it's different i've seen
pitches this year i've never seen in my
life
and really it's hard it's hard yeah it's
just hard
his fastballs are
oh he just froze up uh we have
reconnected with uh fernando tatis
junior
when we uh last left off um
you said that you you're seeing pitches
you've never seen before
explain that to us it's just the
difference it's just better pitches
more spin rate it's just it's just
three minutes way harder this is to hit
but
do you have any problem with pitchers
being allowed to use this kind of
substance sticky stuff to throw
uh well i guess that just depends on the
mlb
i'm going by call you know yeah
but do you think it's unfair because you
have to face these pitches
and the numbers are down for hitters i i
mean everybody's throwing a hundred
and it feels like i mean you got guys
throwing no
hitters uh i mean it they're it's pretty
scary out there i would imagine as a
hitter
well if they're a lot bad they better
expect less from headers
and that's just a fact you know but
what can we say uh
it's just it's just harder man it's hard
pictures are better uh they have better
mechanics and
they have better throwing arms and now
with this uh sticky [ __ ] they have more
spring rate
what's it like to face jacob degrom
um it was amazing it was amazing you
know i'm a guy that loves history
hey that he's one of the best i i
respect
all the respect that from me to him and
as
uh when i was in the home plate i i know
i was facing the gold at the moment
but would you rather face a power
pitcher or if i said clayton kershaw's
on the mound or jacob degrom
uh i like jacob the gum you would want
to face him
yeah because
uh i i just know you're gonna throw me a
fastball
he's one of those guys that's just gonna
overpower you know he has the power and
you know he can challenge you
and he's gonna challenge you without no
fear what is
the what's clayton kershaw's curveball
like
it's a pretty good pitch i think i never
got a hit against it
but it is one of the best pictures i
ever seen
do you guys have an is this uh a
legitimate healthy rivalry
is there bad blood between dodgers
padres
i don't i don't think there's bad blood
in there you know i feel like
we both know we are very good teams and
uh
you know we know the history from from
from the past from these two teams but
i know what we're doing different what
we're doing this year is
we're just playing great baseball we're
facing each other and
we just i feel like we rise the level
when we're facing each other
oh fernando come on you gotta you gotta
spice it up a little bit here
call out trevor balor or something here
no no
[Laughter]
[Music]
what do you think of bauer no you know
bauer is one of those guys that you know
you can play around you know you can
joke
and uh you know uh he's you and the
other days
you're gonna know i feel like you're
just playing around you're just or
you're just around but you know it's one
of the best pictures of the game right
now until
well uh congrats so far on the season we
appreciate your time
and uh thanks for joining us and thank
you
thank you welcome that's fernando tatis
jr